pour commencer le chef de l'état a tenu
une nouvelle fois à rendre hommage au
courage et au dévouement des personnels
soignants qui se sont battus depuis de
longs mois
sur le front du coronavirus il a relevé
des erreurs des problèmes certes mais
comme partout mais dans l'ensemble je
cite ce défi sans précédent a pu être
relevé et l'assaut de cette épidémie a
pu être repoussée même si la baisse des
nouvelles contaminations au niveau
national continue de se poursuivre
vladimir poutine a tenu à mettre en
garde la population russe contre tout
relâchement est juriste estime rich ross
quinzaine en même temps je voudrais dire
tout de suite que la situation reste
compliquée et comme on dit peut basculer
dans n'importe quelle direction
c'est pour cela que nous sommes ici
c'est pourquoi il n'y a aucune raison de
se reposer sur ses lauriers de se
relâcher d'oublier des recommandations
des médecins finir je le répète la
situation se stabilise dans l'ensemble
du pays les régions lève progressivement
le régime des restrictions forcé
l'activité commerciale est rétabli des
productions sont lancés les
établissements de restauration et des
centres commerciaux sont ouverts bien
entendu ce travail peut et doit être
poursuivie de manière cohérente mais il
est nécessaire de ne prendre que des
décisions équilibrées prudente et
précise basée comme auparavant sur les
recommandations des spécialistes car
cette précipitation injustifiée comme
l'a montré la situation dans certaines
régions de la russie s'est traduit par
une seconde augmentation du nombre de
personnes malades
en effet les autorités se préparent
d'ores et déjà la période automne hiver
qui s'annonce et la possible deuxième
vague qui pourraient l'accompagner mais
il ya aussi du nouveau concernant la
recherche et même la mise à disposition
très prochainement de vaccins contre le
coc vite 19mm ouest explique steve les
sites chose c'est mieux de vivre la plus
grande perspective en russie porte
actuellement sur deux vaccins contre le
coronavirus
l'un a été créé par le centre de
recherche en épidémiologie et
microbiologie nicolaï gamaleya en
collaboration avec l'institut central de
recherche numéro 48 du ministère de la
défense pour ce vaccin l'enregistrement
officiel est prévu en outre 2020 sous
conditions c'est à dire après
enregistrement la réalisation des essais
cliniques aura lieu sur 1600 personnes
le lancement de la production
industrielle du vaccin est prévue pour
septembre 2020 un autre vaccin a été
développé par le centre scientifique
d'état vector de lagence rospotrebnadzor
les essais cliniques combinés ont
commencé et leur fin est prévue pour
septembre
en septembre également l'enregistrement
officiel est prévu et le premier lot
devrait être produit en octobre 2020
pire vous partir plagne le président
estime auprès de votre centre good en
attendant les autorités s'affairent pour
que la rentrée de septembre se déroule
dans les conditions les plus normale
possible
l'objectif étant d'éviter autant que
faire se peut de devoir réintroduire des
mesures restrictives de devoir
réintroduire des mesures de confinement